nuevas tumbas que se pierden en el
Horizonte
500 soldados ucranianos que han muerto
en la guerra con Rusia han sido
enterrados aquí en el cementerio de
harquif imágenes del funeral del marido
de esta mujer vital y la frushing un
artillero de 50 años que murió en el
frente de
su hija madre y amigos también deben
despedirse
Por qué tenemos esta guerra en el siglo
XXI no lo entiendo
Nuestros hombres están muriendo que han
hecho para merecerlo
el futuro de nuestro país está muriendo
con cada hombre muerto
no puedo escribir mis emociones están
duro
seis soldados más fueron enterrados en
este cementerio algunos de los
fallecidos son muy jóvenes y muchos de
ellos murieron en los combates
especialmente mortíferos de bakmut
cada día estos Soldados del frente se
codean con la muerte el frente ruso está
a 400 metros entre esos árboles
los combatientes prefieren no hablar de
sus hermanos caídos
las emociones no tienen cabida aquí
[Música]
Esa es la guerra Claro que hay más miedo
que adrenalina pero lo más importante es
mantenerse Unidos y fuertes
[Música]
las autoridades ucranianas dicen que han
perdido alrededor de 13.000 soldados
desde que Rusia invadió
una cifra imposible de verificar este
Comandante por ejemplo se niega a decir
cuántos han muerto en su Batallón
me duele pensar en ello me produce
emociones incontrolables
me convierte en un monstruo hambriento
de venganza
los combates se han intensificado en la
región Rusia y Ucrania se enfrentan por
cada calle de ciudades como bacmut y
Bulevar